I'm done listening to Michael Jackson I
was done way before that hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi I'm Anja volts see I'll let you speak
thank you as you're permitted to thank
you for the permission of course
female guest Sonia she's here on the
channel go follow her on social media
fortunately a woman she is a stand-up
comic you should go check out her videos
that you can check out her website but
also on YouTube there's links in the
description box for you guys and because
she's a comic I figured it's only
appropriate to do a try not to laugh
challenge with her because comics are
all about I shouldn't laugh at other
people's jokes yeah nobody else is funny
cuz cuz that's a good as we say in the
business no laughing
MacFarlane you got me this time we're
[Music]
[Music]
not gonna let this go are you
that - a four-hour erection well she's
long gone so you can go - I don't know
you got me for another three and a half
hours
go ahead seek medical attention I'm not
going anywhere you can't stay I'm
shepard with my daughter's Girl Scout
dinner in 45 minutes well tuck me in
your waistband
trying to pee up your shirt this is
everything left arranged oh well listen
becoming a half-man half-horse
yeah funny because it's not the half you
are expecting that's why Peter
I gotta buy this review because we just
we loved it so much the first time
you're like you're gonna want to see it
again
Hey
right there nice well I made it you made
it I finally made it well represented in
this beautiful collage shout out to all
the reactors nah never mind then nah
they can all go to hell screw everyone
else I know here that's here especially
Tyrone Magnus hate you I laughed yeah
you did I'm not above it you lose five
bucks I do not pay for your uber trip
over here now I uh I do actually I could
give you $5.00 if you really wanted that
would be great I made it from doing
stand-up comedy last night you got you
made five bucks well no I made you guys
I'm hearing all kinds of money I already
spent some of it there you go you're
gonna give that back to me sue it's just
a bit or a mic and you can keep it I
guess I'll pay you five bucks to come on
your channel do you really need five
dollars no no no here come on okay
forward that tiger bit that would
actually work if you wanted to scare
your case scare kids and to actually
being better yeah and raise a sense of
awareness I have to be the best way to
do it oh I think fear is the most
effective teacher that's why I like our
president I think he's doing great do
anything differently we shouldn't
clarify when we're being sarcastic
because the Liberals could take up that
we're being sarcastic that all right
durable think we're being sincere
they're wrong perspective it's four-hour
erection but I've never had an erection
for longer than 10 minutes I don't know
the hell's going on here medication
probably funny funny little bloop ooh
this bit this foo Manchu baby oh yeah no
no what happened there
explain yourself oh do I need to yeah
you do
well it's horribly racist yeah man it's
Family Guy yeah it gets a pass no it
does races and jokes and sexy look
you're a comic I'm hearing comedians all
the time now all this me to stuff is
ruining comedy I just want to make my
jokes I thought you'd be in supportive
racist and or sexist humor much like a
lot of people like to say not all men
not all comedians you know I'm not part
of that particular community that is
trying to die on the hill of being able
to keep doing this [ __ ] well look
let me tell you something first up not
all men line whenever a guy says that
he's lying to you
all right all men are the same I I once
again I disagree trust me off but I
can't trust you on a statement about all
men you were merely one I represent a
good faction okay okay yeah trust once
again I don't have I don't possess all
the necessary assets to have uh I
thought you're gonna say brain sighs
well I did I do have a tiny tiny little
woman brains that see what I was thank
you oh I'm surprised you've comprehended
that without me having oh well it took
me a minute to get there you may recall
but you got and you're really patient
with me and I appreciate that I don't
know if it's good if you're yes Annie me
however somehow I'm still looking
setting feminism back by 50 years and
you know what we like the challenge
funniest bit was the opening bit ya know
the opening literally the opening that
he was opening and it was opening he was
opening a can it was a [ __ ] comedy okay
I need a spoon feed this to you folks
you're intelligent people I'm sure
except for anybody who has any
negative to say about me I got you what
are you gonna do that quarter you get
corn all right well you can subscribe
click notification mouse and check out
on you on social media hey I love that
ah you thought we were still there's a
patron of the day shout out bit that I
did for Luke Anderson on a separate take
but apparently there's no audio for it
so John and I gonna make up for it right
now
picture today shout out for Luke
Anderson I haven't heard from this guy
in many many months there was a time
where him and I were messaging each
other back and forth all the time here's
what I can tell you guys he's a deep
dude he's a philosophical folk he is the
son of oh you believe a pasture with
that in mind I want to tell you there is
no such thing as law of attraction there
is no such thing as God heaven is not
real
I hope this shout-out inspires you to
change your religious and/or spiritual
beliefs because my friend you are
wasting your time believing that level
of nonsense it's not real but hell is
very real yeah and you're living in it
right now
that is real get used to it because
you're evil and bad and we hate you but
we love you because you pledged yeah
money is the root of all happiness they
got that quote wrong thanks for being
here
you might not even watch this I think
your card is just an automatic charge
every month love you buddy